Jean-Vincent Placé et notre invité le
premier de 2014 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous pour faire entendre peut-être
votre impatience ou vos critiques
souvent acerbes sauf si bien sûr vous
avez décidé de changer en cette nouvelle
année vos amis socialistes en tous les
cas rêvent d'une bonne résolution de
votre part Jean Vincent placé patron des
sénateurs écologistes vous serez
interrogé tout à l'heure par katellite
Jean de l'Agence France Presse notre
partenaire pour preuve par 3 avec
Dailymotion et puis par Perrine Tarnaud
de Public Sénat d'abord Jean massant
placé votre avis sur l'interdiction des
spectacles de Dieudonné les mesures se
multiplient un peu partout en France on
va donc d'abord cesser de le qualifier
de comique est-ce que selon vous la
réponse de Manuel Valls a été la bonne
ni comique ni humoriste ni homme de
spectacle en réalité c'est aujourd'hui
un homme politique disons-le qui
professe des thèses antisémites qui sont
totalement inacceptables et qui plus
rien personne sauf effectivement un
public de gens qui sont antisémites et
qui viennent pour cela qui retrouvent
peut-être dans le côté un peu plus soft
de qui se perdent plutôt dans le côté un
peu plus soft de des meetings de Madame
Le Pen et qui retrouve là peut-être un
espace avec des plaisanteries grasses
scandaleuses
qui sont
la réponse de Manuel Valls c'est les
fermes déterminée volontariste et juste
et je suis très content d'ailleurs de
pouvoir soutenir l'action du mise à
l'intérieur sur ce sujet sur ce sujet
de police et de gendarmerie Manuel Valls
c'est un misérateur remarquable et sur
ce sujet qui est extrêmement important
pour nous pour les valeurs de la
République la lutte contre
l'antisémitisme et ça nous phobie le
racisme et bien c'est extrêmement
important d'avoir une réponse politique
voilà parce que à un moment bien sûr il
y a le débat juridique je ne méprise pas
évidemment mais il y a le sujet
politique et à un moment dans un pays
comme le nôtre la France avec ses
valeurs son universalisme son
attachement au droit de l'homme et aux
libertés et bien justement on ne peut
pas accepter de tel propos tenues
de meeting en meeting successifs
d'ailleurs valu des condamnations à
Dieudonné donc vous le répétez Manuel
Valls c'est un ministre de l'Intérieur
remarquable et certains quand même
notamment à l'UMP lui reproche peut-être
d'être trop bavard sur le dossier dans
d'enfer trop voir
d'instrumentaliser cette affaire est-ce
qu'il y a une tentation de diversion
j'ai vu d'ailleurs je m'en réjouis
également le soutien d'une classe
politique plutôt unanime bien sûr je
pense que François Copé j'ai vu aussi à
la GP la réponse à la Juppé et puis
puisque bon voilà la République elle est
là elle nous rassemble je sais que je
dis
peu de choses de positif de Christian
Estrosi mais lui aussi à Nice a une
position extrêmement déterminée mon ami
le maire de Tours pour le coup
socialiste Bruno
Germain Jean Germain pardon Germain
c'est le footballeur c'est la rentrée et
à Nantes aussi bien sûr alors néanmoins
est-ce qu'il a pas le risque de faire de
la publicité à Dieudonné parce que vous
avez vu quand même que partout il devait
se produire les salles étaient en passe
d'afficher complet il a un public et un
public peut-être Nolan curiosité et
piquée c'est un c'est une vraie question
d'évidence
il en joue Monsieur M balade ils ont les
choses comme ça et ça donne mais c'est
une balade et
je vois bien sur les réseaux sociaux il
a toute une audience aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs sur les réseaux sociaux
l'extrême droite est très très forte
elle est très active on le voit aussi
avec les différentes vidéos qui
circulent mais
après voilà un moment dans une prise de
position justement politique et bien il
faut peser le pour et le compte à un
moment il faut agir et je le répète
l'action de de Manuel Valls c'est tout à
fait remarquable aujourd'hui François
Hollande a appelé donc tous les
responsables politiques les préfets à
appliquer la circulaire Valls sur cette
interdiction le chef de l'État que l'on
attend la semaine prochaine pour sa
conférence de presse il va préciser ses
intentions une semaine enfin tous les
cas quelques semaines après ces vœux aux
Français le 31 décembre beaucoup ont
reçu l'intervention du chef de l'État
comme un virage social libéral laisse
votre cas
virage non tournant non plus je trouve
que
y compris il y en a eu des échanges
contradictoires sur le sujet c'est il
assume il assume en réalité plus
nettement en termes de communication
politique à la politique est menée que
vous vous condamnez je la conteste
depuis 18 mois parce que il y a un
équilibre à trouver sur entre assumer
effectivement le traité européen qui met
une évidence quand même beaucoup
d'austérité et des rigueur dans le
budget avec une réforme fiscale qui n'a
pas été aboutie donc l'équilibre entre
la volonté des endettement que y compris
nous partageons nous les écologistes
nous sommes extrêmement attachés est-ce
que ça ne soit pas générations futures
qui paye pour les générations présentes
qu'on ne laisse pas des dettes
s'entasser qu'il y ait un équilibre
entre endettement déficit mais aussi
justice sociale redressement du pays
développement économique et notamment
investissement d'avenir parce que ça
nous y sommes
c'est équilibre là il me semble n'a pas
été trouvé dans les 18 derniers mois
donc moi je vois pas de tournant dans la
politique du président mais je voudrais
juste
faire en sorte que dans cette année il y
ait cet équilibre là
déficites réduits endettement nous y
sommes tous d'accord attentifs cela de
ce doit se faire avec une fiscalité
c'est-à-dire avec des recettes notamment
budget qui soit plus vous êtes des
orientés aujourd'hui
mais quand vous entendez François
Hollande dire il y a trop d'impôts il y
a trop de défense public il y a trop de
charges sur les entreprises trop de
normes les étouffes
de voir ce qui va être précisé
le discours j'attends de voir les actes
les précisions parce que bon ce sont
quand même des termes très généraux ce
qui est logique d'ailleurs pour des
présidentielles de sur ce format 9 10
minutes on peut pas préciser les choses
il y aura la conférence de presse mardi
prochain et puis voilà donc il y a ces
éléments là qui sont plutôt constitutifs
de son action depuis 18 mois vous
constaterez également qu'il y a un
élément supplémentaire qui a été pour la
première fois dit par président de la
République la transition
pour la première fois moi j'avais eu
l'occasion de d'être reçu par le Chef de
l'État avant il vous a entendu avant les
fêtes et justement j'avais dit mais je
pense que il faut absolument faire en
sorte que la question est la transition
énergétique on va en parler tout à la
fois pour les revenus des ménages les
plus modestes et tout à la fois pour
l'emploi écolo et bien bien ce sont des
sujets qui nous intéresse sur la
dimension budgétaire et économique des
bonnes intentions prêtées à François
Hollande
vous aviez dit d'abord que le pacte de
compétitivité c'était la goutte d'eau
mais alors là il parle d'un pacte de
responsabilité et en misant tout sur les
entreprises alors je me sens placé par
rapport à mes propres citations j'avais
plutôt parler de la TVA pour la goutte
d'eau qui d'ailleurs fait partie du
Pacte pour financer pour financer le
crédit d'impôts pour les entreprises
mérite effectivement le crédits les 20
milliards du crédit d'impôts qui sont
plus utilisés d'ailleurs et parce que ça
n'est pas justement à la montée en
charge
pour les entreprises par exemple je vais
mettre en place qui paye
qui paye comment on va trouver cette
fameuse 35 milliards voilà c'est ça la
question c'est le sens de l'attente que
j'ai par rapport aux actes et comment on
va trouver ce financement si c'est par
un financement qui correspond à la
réforme fiscale que nous voulons de nos
propres vœux depuis à la campagne
présidentielle avec par exemple la
fusion d'impôt sur le revenu et la CSG
donc une CSG progressive et que ça soit
cette justice fiscale plus dynamique en
termes de rendement qui finance voilà
après si c'est 35 milliards qui a plutôt
été annoncé de ce que j'ai pu comprendre
l'intervention du président de réduction
des dépenses mais ou 35 milliards on
voit déjà la difficulté qu'on a eu pour
12 milliards de réduction de dépenses
donc là les 35 milliards j'attends de
voir
au marché que passe le Medef qui
d'ailleurs a applaudi dès demain les
vœux du chef de l'État qui dit bah si
vous baissez nos charges là ils disent
100 milliards d'euros on pourra
embaucher un million de personnes en
France ce sont les les deux sujets
effectivement de friction que que nous
avons depuis 18 mois c'est à dire que la
première élément c'est la vision
austérité rigueur budgétaire qui devait
justement réduire notre endettement et
notre déficit c'est pas tout à fait ça
l'endettement augmente quand même on
doit être à 91,92 % dans de dettes on
doit être on devait faire 3 % pour le
déficit on est plutôt à 4 1 donc le fait
que les rentrées fiscales ne sont pas là
que la croissance n'est pas rendez-vous
tout cela voilà c'est c'est le débat
qu'on a eu donc on va pas non plus
rester sur le débat précédent donc il
faut de se tourner vers l'avenir donc
comment retrouver des marges de
manoeuvre et ces marges de manoeuvre là
je ne suis pas sûr que ça soit de cette
façon qu'on les retrouve et le deuxième
élément au-delà de l'aspect budgétaire
et fiscal c'est l'aspect entrepreneurial
il y a eu le président de la République
un accent très fort mis sur l'aspect
entrepreneurial ça à la limite sur ce
sujet là moi j'ai pas de problème
particulier parce que je suis évidemment
d'accord pour dire que ce sont les
entreprises qui créent de l'emploi dans
notre pays seulement voilà comme
justement on le sait il y a un déficit
par exemple de recherche privée voilà
historique depuis Colbert dans notre
pays c'est plutôt l'investissement
public qui produit la dynamique de
l'entreprise privée et c'est là le
problème notamment des investissements
d'avenir et aussi des financements que
j'ai soutenu beaucoup d'ailleurs par la
banque publique d'investissement qui a
fusionné plusieurs dispositifs et là
nous avons besoin de retrouver des
marges de manœuvres donc d'où le débat
que je lis avec l'austérité de la
rigueur parce que comment on fait pour
trouver les dizaines de milliards
d'équilibre pour toute à la fois
investissement d'avenir plus écolo ça
aurait transport sur le numérique sur la
santé sur l'agroalimentaire c'est ce qui
avait été dit par le Premier ministre
jean-martiro notamment à l'été 2013 et
effectivement les financements
entreprises PME PMI et ça ça m'intéresse
beaucoup ça vous intéresse on vous
écoute vous poser des questions que
j'aurai des réponses plus précises du
chef de l'État justement
je vous écoute je me dis que vraiment
François Hollande il devait avoir du mal
à passer aux actes avec une majorité
comme la sienne avec vous évidemment
pour assumer cette nouvelle stratégie
pragmatique
mais la stratégie problématique je vous
dis pour moi elle est pas nouvelle il
l'a déjà depuis 18 mois et je mise
beaucoup son initiative politique
c'est lui qui fixe le cap nous moi je
suis président d'un groupe parlementaire
écologique on est dans la majorité et on
est là au gouvernement
des propositions et des gouvernements et
deux ministres qui sont particulièrement
utiles et nous pesons sur des choix nous
posons sur la contribution climat
énergie nous avons pesé on le verra sur
la transition énergétique avec la
fermeture de Fessenheim l'orientation de
75 à 50% pour la production
d'électricité par voie nucléaire donc il
y a beaucoup de sujets sur lequel nous
sommes actifs nous avons quand même
réussi à faire en sorte que nous
protégeons le pays d'un risque
environnemental majeur c'est-à-dire la
question des gaz de schistes sans les
écologistes au gouvernement il y aurait
aujourd'hui des des puits de caisse de
schiste sur le territoire national en
Seine-et-Marne dans le Gard
dans l'Aveyron voilà il y a la loi
d'interdiction
dans ce pays les lobbies productivistes
et énergétique est plutôt anticollo sont
très très très très fort et je crois que
aujourd'hui nous sommes quelque part et
au gouvernement et dans les institutions
un rempart par rapport à ces lobby et ça
c'est une fierté qu'on peut avoir alors
après on a prolon pas assez de victoire
écologistes c'est pour ça que nous
portons le débat sur des sujets qui
préoccupent et transition énergétique on
pourrait colovation thermique des
bâtiments transports collectifs voilà
une autre un autre monde si je veux dire
un autre monde économique que nous
voulons avant d'y revenir justement je
voudrais savoir si vous êtes
passablement énervé par la volonté de
passer par des ordonnances pour aller
plus vite sur certains dossiers
notamment la simplification
administrative est-ce que vous allez
être réduit sans brancher sa
m'étonneraitive c'est très bien ça c'est
d'ailleurs ça fait 30 ans qu'on le dit
dans dans ce pays le poids
d'administration centrale moi c'est un
des sujets que j'avais abordé avec le
chef de l'État avant avant
thèmes par exemple de Michel Rocard
quand il était à Matignon de Jospin
également t'as pas été à mon avis assez
envisagé dans ce quinquennat c'est
plutôt d'ailleurs à mon avis dans la
réforme administration centrale qu'on
pourrait plutôt trouver les économies
donc vous voyez puisqu'on cherche des
économies il y en a probablement à faire
après qu'on a dit ça la simplification
c'est plutôt positif si la
simplification ça veut pas dire la
réduction des droits des travailleurs ou
alors la réduction de tel ou tel norme
environnemental qui protège notre nature
ou notre environnement et bien ça c'est
ça n'irait pas mais simplifié pour être
plus efficace notamment dans la création
d'entreprise dans la fusion d'entreprise
dans l'acquisition ça c'est très bien
mais pourquoi les ordonnances parce que
en réalité dans un pays comme le nôtre
et quelque part je crois que les
mouvements sociaux qui ont eu lieu
nombreux lourds parfois même quelques
révoltes disons-le
à la fin de l'année 2013 et bien je
crois que quand on veut aller vite
peut-être par exemple le sujet écotaxe
on la bandeau aura également on voit que
à la fin ça bloque et donc moi je ne
crois pas aux ordonnances d'une part
peut-être de façon un peu idéologique
c'est vrai par rapport au rôle du
Parlement mais aussi parce que c'est
justement ce n'est pas efficace et on ne
va pas plus vite en réalité
dans votre vin tiens depuis le début de
cette émission vous montrer que vous
avez peut-être pris de bonnes
résolutions pour 2014 j'en mets sur
place vous vous semblez le confirmer en
opinant mais c'est vrai j'ai pris mais
vous aussi j'espère moi aussi
chaque année
et c'est l'humanisme également c'est
chaque année d'essayer s'améliorer moi
je réussis pas toujours toutes les
années mais je suis parti en effet des
bonnes résolutions
lors de ces vœux vous l'avez rappelé
François Hollande a présenté la
transition énergétique comme l'une de
ces trois décisions majeures cette année
trois priorités cache en fait ces bonnes
intentions on voit tout de suite ça avec
Mounir souci avant d'accueillir quel tel
Prigent de l'Agence France Presse
2014 année de vérité sur le front de
l’écologie en tout cas cette fois c'est
promis fini les discours place aux actes
François Hollande l'affirme dans ses
vœux la révolution verte s'est
maintenant je veux que notre pays
accomplisse sa transition énergétique
avec un calendrier déjà fixé le projet
de loi doit arriver au Parlement après
les municipales et la majorité
socialiste prévient elle ne se laissera
pas déborder par ses partenaires je ne
considère pas que les questions
d'écologie soient l'objet de discussion
avec nos alliés d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts je suis très heureuse que la
formation politique participe au
gouvernement et à la majorité mais ils
ne sont pas porteurs exclusifs des
questions d'écologie le chantier est
immense avec notamment l'objectif de
réduire la consommation énergétique de
moitié d'ici à 2050 et de mettre en
place une fiscalité écologique cohérente
un agenda ambitieux qui fera forcément
beaucoup de déçus selon cette ancienne
secrétaire d'État à l'écologie
pas une seconde dans la parole
présidentielle c'est-à-dire que le
problème qu'on a avec ce gouvernement et
ce président sur la question écologique
c'est que depuis presque deux ans
maintenant tout n'est que mensonge j'ai
trahison on a un discours très ambitieux
sur lequel à la limite il y a pas grand
chose d'ailleurs à redire qui est très
séduisant et puis on a une réalité et
des actes qui sont en contradiction
totale suspension de l'écotaxe recule
sur la taxation du diesel autant de
dossions suspens qui vont polluer le
travail du gouvernement cette année un
gouvernement attendu au tournant par les
ONG
héritées par les hésitations au sommet
de l'État la vraie question ça va être
le niveau d'investissement si quelque
chose est prioritaire ça doit se voir
pour que ça se voit ça doit se voir avec
une mobilisation de moyens combien
l'État va mettre sur la table pour la
transition énergétique pour le président
une enveloppe annuelle de 20 milliards
d'euros sera nécessaire pour financer la
transition énergétique une manne qui
représente 4 fois le budget du ministère
de l'Agriculture voilà donc ça coûte
cher la transition énergétique
qu'a-t-elle une agence transpresse nous
a rejoint bonsoir Katell vos questions
agents
ça coûte très très cher et c'est plutôt
centaines de milliards d'euros
d'investissement qui ont été mis dans le
nucléaire donc
ce n'est pas tout à fait comparable en
terme de
d'échelle Jouanno qui parle de mensonges
et trahison pour François Hollande elle
ne croit pas du tout en ses promesses de
transition écologique pour 2014 est-ce
que vous vous y croyez mais je vais y
croire oui bien sûr le président de la
République
pour la première fois je t'ai dit pour
la première fois le président de la
République la 5e République dit que sa
priorité une de ces trois priorités
cette année c'est la transition
écologique et nous allons avoir la
transition énergétique avec la loi sur
le sujet avant l'été le Premier ministre
s'est engagé ça a été annoncé à la
conférence environnementale en septembre
y compris par le président ça va être un
énorme chamboulement et c'est d'ailleurs
une des raisons pour laquelle nous
participons à ce gouvernement c'est
parce que nous avons conçu avec le
président de la République un accord
politique en effet sur la réduction de
75 à 50% de production d'électricité par
voire nucléaire une volonté de réduire
la consommation énergétique et volonté
de relancer les politiques en
particulier publique d'ailleurs
vis-à-vis des énergies renouvelables
donc ça sera un vrai sujet parce
qu'effectivement et bon on parlait avec
Michel grossir combien d'argent BPI je
t'ai dit avec quel outil de quel montant
sur quel investissement notamment les
investissements
homo mais il faut des actes il faut un
cas écologique on a quand même
l'impression que ça fait déjà un an vous
dites au Président il faut un cap il
faut des actes il faut est-ce que on
repart dans un cycle de on demande au
Président cap on demande des actes et on
attend non je pense que là il y a une
volonté de part et d'autre d'ailleurs
chez grossir avec sa subtilité
habituelle à souligner le ton
avant les fêtes on a eu des discussions
de nombreuses avec le Premier ministre
le I feel partant régulièrement avec
Pierre Moscovici enfin Bernard Cazeneuve
c'est-à-dire que aujourd'hui et c'est
Provence qui a péché dans les 18
premiers mois on est allé très très vite
dans les habitudes à 5e République le
pouvoir exécutif on a à peu près tous
les pouvoirs sur la 5ème République on
est président et premier ministre et le
gouvernement et hop on déroule une
politique qu'on a à priori déroulé
justement pendant la campagne
présidentielle et on voit les priorités
qui ont été menées et j'étais toujours
dit les priorités des 18 derniers mois
ont compté simplement pas été très
écologique là et c'est pas je crois
seulement l'effet de notre pression
politique c'est aussi parce qu'il y a
une prise en compte des problématiques
de la planète du souci sincère de
trouver l'équilibre entre le
développement et l'écologie et aussi
j'espère qu'il y a une prise de
conscience sur la préparation de la
conférence climat de 2015 qui aura lieu
en France donc ça c'est extrêmement
important et donc dire que économie 14
en France il y a cette transition
écologique qui va se mettre en place
avec la loi de transition énergétique
avec aussi la loi cadre soit
biodiversité d'ailleurs
en ça n'a pas été tellement cité depuis
quelques semaines et donc comme je vois
les différents responsables dans les
jours à venir je reviendrai à la chasse
au sujet et vous l'avez compris aussi en
termes de débat et de discussion de la
majorité parlementaire notamment dans le
cas de la préparation du budget tous ces
tout à la fois le PLF que le pfss moi je
souhaite avoir une discussion en amont
chez diabernard Cazal très précisément
on ne peut plus accepter
qu'effectivement on fasse les lettres
plancher d'ailleurs pour le coup des
budgets que ensuite il y ait pas de
discussion réelle sur la réforme fiscale
et puis on nous fasse voter des budgets
comme ça a pu été le faire c'était le
cas depuis deux ans c'est pas un peu
trop tard vous ne commencez pas vous les
écologistes à commencer à le payer
c'est-à-dire avec l'UDI qui vient un
petit peu marcher sur vos blagues
demandes en demandant des écologistes
réunir les écologistes du centre la
route ou qui est aussi nouvelle qui m'a
déjà été rejoint par Madame Attar qui
vous a quitté tous les déçus
par s'éparpiller et est-ce que pour les
électeurs ce sera pas est-ce que pour
les acteurs ce sera pas pareil avec les
Européens nous sommes terrorisés par les
hordes de nouveaux écologistes et vous
indiquez et peut-être par vos militaires
vos propres militaires nous avons nous
avons une période qui est difficile qui
correspond à temps difficile pour la
planète attend difficile pour l'Europe
un temps difficile pour le pays en temps
difficile pour la majorité on est dans
le gouvernement il est prolon plus
facile d'être à côté du gouvernement de
faire Mélenchon de de critiquer tout et
encore on va pas te tellement le
déboucher bon les centrisme ils sont
centristes voilà madame Jouanneau elle
était ministre de l'Écologie de Monsieur
Sarkozy donc bon je suis désolé mais
enfin sur les bilans c'est à peu près
le bilan du Grenelle de l'environnement
est supérieur est-ce qu'elle fait la
gauche depuis 18 mois
de
2007-2009
du Grenelle 1 a été très bon c'était il
y a eu 240 préconisations aucune n'a été
mise en place et le président de la
République Nicolas Sarkozy après les
régionales de 2010 a dit maintenant ça
suffit l'écologie j'en ai marre et
Madame Jouanno était là madame
elle était là donc ce ne sont pas eux
qui vont nous donner des leçons et puis
bon monsieur larotoureau bon lui c'est
le spécialiste des nouveaux partis tous
les trois ans bon voilà enfin vous avez
entendu quand même dans le reportage à
l'instant de Mounir souci c'est pas vous
les Verts qui allaient forcément leader
sur le dossier énergétique sur la
transition
les socialistes seront à la pointe du
combat c'est pas vous j'espère mais nous
alors
très sincèrement si un jour il y a plus
besoin d'un parti écologiste pour porter
l'écologie ça m'ira très bien c'est pas
le problème nous on veut justement que
on protège la planète on lutte contre
des réunions climatiques on fasse
attention à biodiversité on change de
modèle agroalimentaire et que il y ait
une autre vision de la transition
énergétique et on pense que c'est bien
pour d'une part les revenus et les
dépenses des ménages et on pense que
c'est bien pour l'emploi donc c'est
c'est ça les idées qu'on porte après
qu'on a dit ça si et Laurence Rossignol
est très sincère elle est secrétaire
nationale environnement du socialisme et
enfin travaille remarquable on a
beaucoup travaillé avec elle dans le cas
de de la cour politique nous avons passé
pour les législatives Philippe partage
et bon espoir qu'il se qu'ils prennent
ça en charge directement voilà donc dans
le cadre de ces nouveaux accommodements
j'ai envie de dire entre les socialistes
réduction de la part du nucléaire
réduction la consommation énergétique il
faut vraiment qu'on incite
et lui dit du j'appliquerai la loi ce
qui est plutôt bien pour le PDG de EDF
et donc il faut pour très simplement
parce qu'on connaît ses convictions sur
le nucléaire et puis à la limite c'est
sans problème parce que il doit puisque
il est Président Directeur Général def
obéir la puissance publique et au
gouvernement donc le gouvernement doit
faire des propositions le Parlement doit
voter cette trajectoire et cohérente
d'ici 2025 de réduction de la part du
nucléaire et donc effectivement
commencer par fermer des centrales et
des réacteurs et évidemment tenir sur
Fessenheim
vous savez il est pas encore ouvert le
pain il a déjà triplé vous allez dire
tripler non mais il a triplé de de coups
depuis le début et les délais ont
également été multipliés par 3 donc
j'attends de voir ce qu'il en sera moi
j'ai toujours dit qu'il serait pas
opérationnel pendant le quinquennat et
j'ai quand même l'impression que les
faits me donne raison avant d'avoir
d'autres sujets Catel une question
est-ce que dans le cadre de ce nouveau
vous avez commisments entre les
socialistes et les Verts sans revenir
dans les détails est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à accepter l'aéroport
Notre-Dame-des-Landes je ne peux pas
vous laisser dire des petits
accommodements c'est que à un moment
lorsqu'on réussit à convaincre
politiquement sur le fond et que le
Président de la République dit une de
mes priorités 2014 c'est la transition
écologique et bien c'est pas un petit
commandement c'est pour le coup là un
virage politique vous devriez plutôt
indiquer je vais vous dire tiens on va
se dire même la vérité je suis frappé de
voir à quel point toute la presse
notamment économique
patronale disons un peu orienté de
droite politique c'est ami énormément
l'accent sur le virage social libéral
etc en faisant des tonnes
et pas une ligne sur la transition
écologique
dans le discours qu'on a quand même plus
sur je vois quand même l'appétit qui a
cette presse et ses médias pour tout ce
qui rapproche d'un libéralisme qu'il
souhaite plutôt que d'un sujet
énergétique lourd qui est vise
effectivement à des réglementations
du président qui effectivement n'a pas
développé
c'est que je m'en réjouis
écologique une de ses priorités pour
2014 grand virage vous estimez donc le
projet de l'aéroport de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes ne peut pas voir
le jour oui ils sont dit ça depuis le
début je crois que on voit pas du
gouvernement
il y a des
préfet a fait son travail il a pris des
arrêtés nous on fait des recours on
continue le débat par rapport à
l'emprise par rapport aux zones humides
par rapport à la biodiversité par
rapport aux problèmes de le politique de
l'eau on continue le combat et
d'ailleurs nous serons je serai le 22
février
on a tout type de renfort on a même les
bonnets rouges je sais pas si nous on
fera les
bonnes espérons d'ailleurs qu'il fera
assez beau pour qu'elle n'ait pas besoin
de bonnet les bonnets rouges et les
kotax toujours Emmanuel cosse votre
secrétaire national dit et je m'en
réjouis un très très bon début et notre
patronne du parti Emmanuel cosse et bien
je suis très complet
sera mise en place en 2014 elle y croit
et là vous avez des assurances du chef
de l'État
on va finir on va bientôt payer
pénalités il y a le PDG des comouves qui
vient demain au Sénat vous le savez avec
la commission d'enquête qui a été mis en
place dans quelle commission d'enquête
il y a des réflexions des renégociations
moi j'espère que les contacts sera mise
en place avant l'été avant l'été
d'argent parlons des contraventions et
des PV où on est de vous de vous
remboursement de ces 18000 euros de PV
impayés l'ensemble du dossier
vous avez tout remboursé tout réglé
échelonner ce que vous avez compris que
les gens aient été choqués par
le fait dans une émission avant les
fêtes également bien sûr bien sûr je
comprends je pouvais pas ma pesantir sur
les circonstances avant 2010 il y a 4
ans maintenant
des mauvaises habitudes évidemment
injustifiable inexusable je l'ai dit
j'ai même présenté des excuses j'ai payé
voilà vous estimez que cet ardoise 18000
euros a pu être instrumentalisé par
certaines de vos amis politiques ça
vient du conseil régional
comme vous êtes bien informé vous
connaissez les réponses aux questions
que vous posez et je suis assez gentil
pour prendre tout ça sur moi voilà
d'accord très bien en tous les cas vous
avez fait votre Miya cool pas vous ferez
attention dorénavant aux excès de
vitesse
une petite question encore peut-être sur
les municipales les scrutins qui
s'annonce ou également les européennes
ou la les sondages sont pas très
favorables pour les Verts
les municipales pourquoi vous dites que
c'est pas favorable
pour les municipales on est dans la
plupart des grandes villes présentes
Paris Lyon Toulouse Nantes Strasbourg
Lille on est crédité entre 7 et 12% qui
sont des scores particulièrement
honorables pour les européennes
oui donc justement j'en étais aux
municipal et
après bon
mais c'est un vrai sujet c'est à dire
que quand on est à une élection
européenne qui passent pas beaucoup les
Français ou c'est très difficile
d'animer le débat dans une situation en
plus la question européenne aujourd'hui
est quand même fortement contesté parce
qu'elle s'apparente justement tellement
libéralisme que c'est compliqué pour un
parti comme le nôtre extrêmement
fédéraliste de porter l'idée européenne
et bien c'est vrai que quand la fouille
et l'enthousiasme Daniel Cohn-Bendit
c'est évidemment plus dur c'est comme
j'ai dit souvent l'équipe de France sans
Zidane ça vachement bien alors il vous
manque un Zidane pour ce scrutin des
européennes merci Katel faire une
tarnote publique c'est Nava arriver
maintenant je reste en placer avant ça
on va voir comment vous avez beaucoup
chauffé les oreilles de vos amis
politiques pas seulement socialiste
d'ailleurs au cours de l'année écoulée
mais là on a bien compris que vous avez
décidé je veux pas dire que vous rentrez
dans le rang parce que vous allez me
reprendre en tous les cas vous avez
affiché ici même vous bottes de
résolution pour l'année nouvelle Mounir
souci
provoque et attire les critiques y
compris à gauche lors de l'affaire
léonarda il demande au lycéen de
descendre dans la rue les socialistes
s'indignent au PS ont l'accuse de
toujours taper pour amuser la galerie
François epsamen vont en lui un garçon
sympathique qui ne peut s'empêcher de
dire des conneries chaque semaine pas
facile la cohabitation entre les vers et
les socialistes chez des partenaires qui
parfois sont agaçants sont agaçants pour
la majorité mais ils sont agaçants pour
eux-mêmes s'ils se regardent bien je les
appelle pour eux d'ailleurs pour nous
pour la gauche à retrouver leurs esprits
et à être unis celui qui voulait être
ministre ne rate pas une occasion de
taper sur l'exécutif et ça énerve
d'agréable mais quelqu'un qui est
capable de sortir une pointe une attaque
en règle alors que finalement il le fait
que par pure tactique une tactique qui
agace aussi les siens beaucoup voient
derrière les critiques récurrentes de
Jean-Vincent Placé une trop grande
ambition personnelle car trop vouloir
faire entendre sa voix peut aussi
brouiller le message politique je pense
qu'il y a une forme d'immaturité à
alimenter en permanence la polémique
finalement
les pics les plus Acer viennent de son
propre camp en privé ses amis assure que
la seule ligne de Jean-Vincent Placé
c'est le pouvoir bien plus important que
les idées
voilà donc pour ce que Sandra cerquera a
pu recueillir sur tout ce qu'on dit sur
vous et qu'il va falloir donc réviser un
petit peu orienter quand même hein
j'ai remarqué que j'avais quelques amis
qui de temps en temps était interviewés
qui m'ont dit c'est on est sûr de pas
passer parce qu'on a dit du bien de toi
j'ai les noms
ça me fait pas particulièrement rire
mais c'est vrai que ce qui ressort des
gens qu'on va interviewer c'est le côté
un peu personnel ambitieux plutôt que
les idées parce que j'ai toujours assumé
la politique sans ambition je voudrais
savoir d'une partie
la fait sans ambition déjà pour ses
idées pour se reposer politique publique
à mettre en place et puis de fait un
moment on se dit que si on demande le
suffrage des électeurs c'est qu'on pense
qu'on est un petit peu capable de faire
en sorte de s'occuper des autres donc
c'est pas nul non plus et moi je vais
vous dire je fais surtout la politique
sans hypocrisie
contrairement à d'autres je suis
d'ajouter bien sûr mais peut-être qui je
les gens
c'est peut-être qui ce qui gênent les
autres personnalités dans le monde
politique c'est cette façon vous avez de
vous promener dans ce monde politique
avec un air détaché dans le style rien
ne m'attend et donc finalement on ne
sait pas si c'est une posture ou c'est
le vrai Jean-Vincent Placé moi je suis
vous dire très franchement je suis pas
sûr que l'objectif de la vie politique
s'assoit de montrer ses états d'âme ou
ou de dire qu'on doute bon j'ai compris
que maintenant on était très dans le
prix très introspectif donc je vais pas
tenir de grands discours de savoir ce
que les uns les autres auraient fait en
40 ou en 58 en 80 etc et un moment je
pense que à responsable politique ça
doit être quelqu'un qui qui est clair
dans sa tête quoi
j'ai l'impression qu'on a depuis le
début de cette émission au delà de ce
virage que vous avez évoqué le virage du
chef de l'État sur les dossiers
énergétiques notamment vous avez
peut-être envie que le regard sur vous
change
je vais vous dire je suis propre
persuadé que si j'avais un communicant
ce qui n'est pas le cas il me dirait à
ce moment-là il faut que tu répondes oui
c'est important etc non moi je le
regarde non mais c'est vrai je vous
cache pas que ce qui m'intéresse c'est
vraiment de faire des choses quoi de
porter des idées justement vous auriez
peut-être envie de servir une autre
cause et vous en avez un peu marre
finalement ce milieu un peu dur de la
politique où les choses n'avancent pas
forcément comme vous le souhaiteriez ah
ça c'est un c'est un vrai débat
c'est-à-dire qu'à un moment c'est vrai
que
on peut raisonnablement se poser la
question en 2014 justement dans dans la
vie politique c'est est-ce que c'est
dans le champ politique on fait le plus
avancer ses idées de voir par exemple
Nicolas Hulot bon même si il a quand
même une soucis à la fin de de
rentrer aussi même si on n'est pas
rentré très longtemps dans le champ
politique ça c'est un vrai débat est-ce
qu'on porte plus avec une ONG est-ce
qu'on porte plus dans des agences de
communication est-ce qu'on porte plus
dans une entreprise moi je l'ai toujours
eu cette tentation de Venise parce que
j'ai
c'était un terme qui était utilisé par
la Juppé lorsqu'il a voulu un peu
décrocher de la vie politique et
au fond je pense qu'à titre personnel
aujourd'hui je pourrais faire beaucoup
d'autres choses je sais pas attention de
pouvoir dire ça je crois en revanche et
c'est le vrai sujet d'ailleurs de
l'écologie politique et du fait partie
d'air et du fait aussi effectivement
qu'on s'occupe d'un appareil politique
etc ce qu'on trouve tout à fait normal
par exemple pour François Hollande mais
qu'on trouve choquant pour les Verts
c'est ça que qui qui
est le propre des versets d'ailleurs y
compris c'est logique qu'on subisse
parfois quelques sarcases qu'on donne
une tonne on a tellement donné de leçons
sur la politique autrement etc etc en
réalité on l'a fait plutôt vraiment
parce que c'est ça qui est important pas
forcément comme les autres je le dis
toujours parce que justement nous pour
le coup sur sur les questions notamment
d'ailleurs financières on n'a jamais eu
de lien avec des entreprises ou des
choses comme ça on est très attachés en
accumul des mandats on a toujours mis en
avant la parité depuis très longtemps
voilà il y a une demi-vanie il y a eu
Cécile Duflot il y a Emmanuel cosse donc
on fait quand même la politique
différemment voilà il faut maintenant la
faire vraiment et après
on a quand même
pas ça c'est que l'histoire des postes
vous êtes journaliste je suis sûr que un
jour vous voudrez avoir plus d'audience
encore comme journaliste et parce que
vous êtes un bon journaliste et vous
savez utile
prochain non je l'ai dit plusieurs fois
dans différents supports
qu'effectivement j'avais un petit peu
couru après ça
non pas du tout donnant pas du tout je
sais pas si si vous développez votre
théorie Perrine par nos sur d'autres
champs d'activités sur sur le déjà pour
le gouvernement
mais
quelque part et je le dis avec en plus
le respect que je j'ai réellement pour
ceci du feu parce qu'à Camphin qui font
un vrai boulot moi pour ma part je pense
que j'ai trouvé un lieu d'influence avec
la présidence de ce groupe parlementaire
ou je crois que je suis assez reconnu et
je pense que je suis très bien où je
suis comme vous vous êtes entretenu il y
a quelques semaines avec François
Hollande est-ce qu'il a trouvé les mots
et ce qu'il a fait appel à son sens de
l'humour pour vous rappeler que vous
étiez peut-être aller trop loin que vous
aviez lancé le bouchon trop loin parfois
oh c'est pas du tout le genre du chef de
l'État et d'ailleurs
non on était vraiment une très bonne
discussion de plus d'une heure sur le
fond non mais
je suis désolé
on a parlé de la série on a parlé de
l'Europe
situation c'est terrible de dire ce que
vous venez de dire c'est à dire je viens
de vous parler à ça
on a parlé de la politique nationale des
différents sujets que vous avez abordés
moi j'ai parlé de réformation j'ai même
parlé de vous en parlez pas parler de
réformes institutionnelle et même de
proportionnelle j'ai parlé de réformes
de l'État je parlais de réforme de
décentralisation qui n'est pas allé
assez loin notamment sur la loi
métropole moi je suis pas suppression et
conseil généraux et
le sujet décentralisation a également
été abordé par le chef et j'ai
évidemment parlé de l'écologie la
transition écologique et puis nous avons
aussi abordé les échanges à venir c'est
bien naturel trois
questions qui ne reviendra sans doute
pas en France en tout cas si les
conclusions du rapporteur public du
tribunal administratif
conclusion du rapporteur public elle
reviendra sans doute à 99%
à faire vous reconnaissez aujourd'hui
avoir un peu dérapé après avoir appelé
les jeunes à manifester dans la rue
manifester j'ai dit que non non
je remercie d'ailleurs l'ASP et la
journaliste précédente qui était là
parce que j'avais
soutenu la mobilisation étudiante
soutenue à mobilisation étudiante
c'était d'ailleurs le communiqué de
presse du parti de Pascal Durand notre
secrétaire national et par un petit
effet sémantique au bout de trois heures
c'est devenu après La Dépêche un appel à
la mobilisation lycéenne alors je vais
vous dire les choses très clairement moi
je ne regrette pas je ne regrette pas
pouvoir soutenu léonarda après vu le
bruit que ça a fait ils ont
l'incompréhension que ça suscité et bien
je le dis aujourd'hui je ne redirai pas
les choses dans les mêmes termes c'est
clair voilà une jambe placé le bureau du
Sénat statut demain sur la demande de
levée d'immunité parlementaire du
sénateur certes d'assaut la justice le
demande est-ce que le Sénat doit aller
dans son sens moi je vais vous dire
aussi très franchement les choses le
l'immunité parlementaire c'est un sujet
important qui a été mis en place une
autre période où justement vous les
protéger les parlementaires par rapport
au pouvoir du roi au pouvoir de justice
d'ailleurs de roi de saisie physique des
parlementaires et cela a perduré sur la
République donc c'est quelque chose
d'important tant sur
l'irresponsabilité que sur
l'inviolabilité même s'il y a eu et
c'est bien logique des réformes qui
ont tenu compte de la situation moderne
et y compris d'ailleurs du fait que nous
soyons dans des républiques et il y a en
revanche après cet élément de principe
je pense important il y a un autre
élément qui est encore plus lourd sur le
plan du principe c'est toute la
procédure est soumise au secret
d'instruction c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui moi je ne connais pas ni
évidemment le commentaire le bureau
du procureur il va y avoir un
vice-président qui est Jean Léonce
Dupont qui va
un vice-président qui s'appelle
Jean-Louis Dupont qui va rapporter
demain devant le bureau du Sénat et le
rapport et les délibérations et le
résultat sont soumis au secret de
l'instruction donc vous m'en voudrez pas
de ne pas épiloguer son sujet moi ce que
je souhaite ce que je souhaite c'est que
on vérifie que tous les moyens sont
donnés à la justice pour agir voilà le
sens qui doit être très clair de la
décision qui doit tomber de l'immunité
Parlement ça dépend et du rapport et la
discussion qui aura lieu demain et si
j'étais au bureau
la même chose à chaque fois je l'ai dit
pour d'ailleurs quand on est dans
l'opposition la majorité je dis moi la
même chose c'est-à-dire que quand il y a
eu verf Bettencourt Sarkozy j'ai dit la
même chose quand j'étais dans
l'opposition j'ai même dit la même chose
pour Jérôme Cahuzac ça m'a été compris
reproché par mes propres amis secret
d'instruction séparation des pouvoirs et
le juge et bien il fait son travail très
bien la décision du Bureau du Sénat
sachant que des groupes comme le Parti
communiste par exemple a demandé la
levée de l'immunité parlementaire on a
entendu effectivement votre position je
me sens placé merci d'avoir été avec
nous aujourd'hui merci à Perrine à la
semaine prochaine